[Musica]
no
si no
[Musica]
sì
beh che cosa guardate qua a vigili del
cev
ciao ciao a tutti è un piacere essere
qui
vi ringrazio chiedo scusa agli amicì
internazionali se non parlo in inglese
ma preferisco ogni volta parlare
direttamente con le persone che ho
davanti perché non parlo con le masse ma
parlo uno per uno uno per uno
ecco questo giro del mondo per gli
orfani per gli offrono trophy che ho
fatto è stata l'esperienza più bella
della mia vita
sono tornato ieri dalla nigeria non
c'entrava niente con quel giro del mondo
per gli orfanotrofi ma una splendida
donna italiana che ha detto andrea per
il tuo compleanno il 23 aprile è giusto
che fa giocare con i bambini ti regalo
questo biglietto per andare in questa
isola che non esiste se la cercate su
google non c'è il bad horse e nigeria
infatti a divertire ho detto grazie
accettato volentieri questo splendido
regalo ma una domanda che mi hanno fatto
in molti è stato il perché ho deciso di
fare il giro del mondo per gli
orfanotrofi
il mio sogno da piccolo era quello di
fare il magistrato di combattere contro
la mafia perché dopo in siciliano preso
questi qua come veri esenti come modelli
persone che hanno deciso di non avere
paura di vedere di sentire di ascoltare
di relazionarsi con gli altri
e allora quando a 15 anni che è stato
diagnosticato un tumore cerebrale sono
diventato dopo questo tumore
un ragazzo con difficoltà di memoria
infatti prima dell'operazione alla testa
ero andato benissimo a scuola senza
studiare mai niente dopo l'operazione
alla testa
ho iniziato a delle difficoltà non mi
ricordavo più le cose non mi ricordavo
nemmeno le persone con cui avevo anche
relazioni ho detto ma com'è possibile
questa questa cosa sono adesso un
memoria 0 non posso fare più il
magistrato immaginatevi studiare le
leggi e quindi affrontato gli anni con
l'aiuto dei professori mi facevano fare
l'inter
reazioni a poco a poco mi chiami di
san'andrea gita la senti di essere
interrogato quindi anche in una maniera
un po diversa
all'inizio rispetto agli altri con
qualcosa che mi ha cambiato la vita è
stato quando a 19 anni per la prima
volta sono finito in peter magis burg un
paese della del sudafrica dove con una
onlus siciliana abbiamo fatto aprire un
centro pediatrico per bambini
raccogliendo in due anni 620mila euro
grazie anche a delle donazioni di quel
progetto sono veramente allo 0,001 per
cento del successo però mi sento parte
di quella di quella squadra è la cosa
assurda è stata che io già ho viaggiato
tantissimo ma ogni volta che ritornava a
casa ciò che ho fatto
burke spa visto la stato della libertà
ha visto torre eiffel ma a parte quelle
immagini non avevo molti ricordi dei
viaggi quando sono tornato la prima
volta dal dal sudafrica la cosa
straordinaria è stata che ho detto
aspetta me mi ricordo tutti i bambini
con cui ho fatto attività perché ero
andato in un orfanotrofio mi ricordò i
giochi che abbiamo fatto i loro volti
detto manuela forse anch'io un po di
finti memoria ho iniziato a studiare
delle tecniche alternative di memoria
per memorizzare e ho scoperto che tutte
le cose che toccano le nostre emozioni
i nostri sentimenti passano
automaticamente dalla memoria a breve
termine alla memoria a lungo termine
quindi ho iniziato a trasformare tutte
le cose che studiavo non soltanto in
sentimenti ma anche in in immagini
perché se adesso dovessi prendervi un
libro vi faccio vedere questo libro per
5 secondi
ve lo chiudo vi dico che cosa vi
ricordate di questo libro
il genio io mi ricordo cinque parole una
persona normale
123 parola io forse la lettera con la in
grassetto il numero che leggo
al di sotto della pagina ma una cosa
straordinaria invece se dovessi
prendervi qua un quadro vi faccio vedere
questo quadro 5 secondi lo stesso arco
di tempo velo giro e vi dico che cosa vi
ricordate di questo quadro vi ricordate
i colori vi ricordate che stiamo a roma
perché c'è il colosseo
vi ricordate che c'è una famiglia ci
sono dei bambini c'è la luna quindi è
notte
quindi attraverso le immagini possiamo
memorizzare pura e quindi io quando sono
tornato e ho fatto queste tecniche di
memoria subito dopo il sudafrica ho
fatto un miracolo lo possiamo chiamare
così perché ho dei test mnemonici
neurologici non mi ricordo nemmeno il
nome del tumore che ho avuto
ma sono riuscito nonostante questi test
dicessero che non potevo andare avanti
non potevo a prendere altre lingue
non poteva andare da nessuna parte mi
sono laureato preso il master ed ho
parlato mese fa il 20 un mese e mezzo fa
il 20 di marzo alle nazioni unite l'onu
come perché era la giornata della
felicità quindi ne hanno invitato ed è
stato bello perché devo parlare in
italiano invece poi ho deciso di parlare
in inglese per dimostrare come dobbiamo
credere in noi stessi per fare un
qualcosa di più della nostra vita il
primo ascoltato jovanotti è detto
bisogna viaggiare una cosa verissima per
avere 26 anni fatti da poco sono stato
in più di 90 nazioni sono stati in tutti
i continenti
amo proprio vivere viaggiare e quindi
quando io avevo un lavoro un posto fisso
che in italia è una cosa assurda quando
questo posto fisso
l'ho buttato via perché ho pensato
aspetta ma la vita è soltanto una io la
voglio vivere come come la voglio io
il mio sogno era di essere il primo
nella storia a fare qualcosa ha detto
cosa posso fare non sono un genio non
possa inventare del dei farmaci che
facciano quelli delle vita ma ho pensato
di fare un qualcosa che potesse essere
per me davvero bello e quindi ho pensato
amo viaggiare amo giocare con i bambini
soprattutto orfani quindi sarò il primo
della storia a fare questo giro del
mondo per gli orfanotrofi
ed è stata un successo perché io sono
partita avevo un budget di 4 mila euro
mi seguivano 200 persone attraverso i
social network attraverso facebook
adesso giochiamo a 120 mila persona
adesso con qualcosa di straordinario
perché io sono partito sono andato nello
sri lanka india nepal cambogia vietnam
thailandia brasile paraguay bolivia perù
ecuador colombia
new york etiopia uganda ruanda sono
restano ganda repubblica democratica del
congo dove mi hanno cacciato perché non
ho voluto pagare il pizzo
quindi sono stato un extracomunitario in
nella repubblica democratica del congo
per 4 ore e quindi dopo questo giro del
mondo per gli orfanotrofi ho scoperto
quella qual era il mio progetto ideale
di fare un viaggio che potessi
ricordarmi per tutta la vita
ed è stato così è durato nel 2015
il mio obiettivo era di andare a fare
attività con mille i bambini invece non
fatte con 8800 di bambini ed è stato
bello perché questi bambini e non
volevano chissà che cosa questi bambini
che devono una cosa che purtroppo nei
posti poveri manca l'affetto qualcuno
che li faccia sentire importanti e il
mio successo più grande non è stato
quello che ora mi hanno invitato alle
nazioni unite che uscirà il mio libro
con una grande casa editrice che mi
hanno fatto interviste varie testate
giornalistiche no il mio più grande
successo è stato sapere che quei bambini
che prima erano in mezzo alla strada o
dimenticati dal nulla adesso hanno un
sogno anche allora è quello là di
crescere di viaggiare di aiutare gli
altri bambini più piccoli per me questo
qua ragazzi è stata ma un successo
straordinario perché il successo non è
quella cosa che è che ci danno
il successo non è vi faccio un esempio
il mio libro che è infatti forse il
titolo era sbagliato mi sembra si
chiamerà arcobaleno dove nasce dal
cubano che non mi ricordo nemmeno vi ho
scritto questo libro non ho riletto
nemmeno una pagina quindi non vi posso
consigliare di comprarlo non so se un
bel libro oppure no qualcuno secondo
leggere mi dirà cosa ne pensa
ma una cosa che mi hanno chiesto in
molte persone mi hanno detto andrea tu
hai fatto il giro del mondo ti si è
sacrificato stai scritto questo libro
perché io ho problemi anche di
concentrazione quindi per me scrivere
molto pesante mi hanno detto perché è
deciso di donare il tuo libro ancora
cioè perché non utilizzi quei soldi per
te per comprarti una macchina invece lo
dai in beneficenza in in etiopia andrà a
finire alla bus ai onlus e ho detto ma
riflettete
cos'è più bello che con i soldi di quel
libro mi compro una macchina mi compro
una casa oppure con quei soldi di quel
libro possa aprire una scuola un
ospedale
posso salvare delle vite posso dare
l'istruzione io credo che la risposta
vera sia la seconda perché per amare la
vita
non dobbiamo veramente pensare chissà
che cosa per amare la vita dobbiamo
essere felici ma lo dobbiamo scegliere
la mattina al pomeriggio la sera cioè io
non sono più triste
dico purtroppo perché il disagio ogni
tanto capita qualcosa di brutto
dico andiamo come farà un essere che ci
devo fare ma sono fatto così l'unica
volta che sono stato triste negli ultimi
dieci anni da quando l'operazione è
stato un tentato omicidio che ho subito
in in colombia ma non ne parliamo adesso
ha una storia molto complicato come
vedete io passo da un argomento
all'altro perché se dovessi farmi la
scaletta non me la ricorderei e quindi
una cosa che voglio dire è che questa
felicità deve essere nostra se c'è
possibilmente il sole qualcuno dire ciò
che giornata calda che sfortuna c'è la
pioggia che giornata brutta c'è la
pioggia non etico che bello oggi c'è il
sole si sta bene
uscita moneyreport è imposta bron tare
ma questo acqua in africa oppure invece
c'è la pioggia finalmente un po d'aria
fresca
dobbiamo essere ottimisti quindi una
cosa che consiglio a tutti quanti voi
veramente di pensare con semplicità che
la vita è soltanto una e della cosa più
bella del mondo vi ringrazio per questo
tempo che vi ho dedicato
ho cercato veramente di perché capisco
questa significa andare ad ascoltare
tante persone la concentrazione si perde
vi annoiate vi stancate se volete a
scrivermi a parlarne alla fine rimarrò
qui fino alla fine per salutarvi vi può
accedere proprio il giro del mondo per
gli orfanotrofi in tre minuti con la
voce del mio caro amico giovanni caccamo
campione l'anno scorso di sanremo
giovani quest'anno è arrivato terzo dove
di mostro come le culture nel mondo sono
diverse ma i bambini sono uguali
grazie
[Applauso]
che mai a juve laica
[Musica]
l'on
pioggia stipendi
stavo dio
[Musica]
no no
baby
[Musica]
bei castelli
io
coprire
[Musica]
now there sa e fa un dio stesso
baby 6 giu
ché io ve la faccio io somma
[Musica]
io gesti
grazie grazie a tutti gli voglio tanto
bene
ciao viva la vita